The holidays are a time to be kind to one
another. To show each other generosity, even
if we get nothing in return. That’s why
I think the season’s mascot should be the
vampire bat. You heard me.
Hey festive friends, Julian here for DNews.
Bats get a bad rap for pretty much no reason.
Some of them eat fruit, a lot of them eat
insects, but three species out of 1300 suck
blood and suddenly they’re associated with
Count Dracula forever. It’s just three!
Three species! [[count laugh]]
So I’m here today to try and convince you
that bats should be a symbol of the holiday
season. And because I like making my life
difficult, I’m going to nominate the vampire
bat.
First off I am going to temper the freaky
factor of vampire bats by saying that them
sucking blood isn’t even that bad. Ok it’s
still pretty freaky but hear me out. First
off, they don’t drink enough blood to harm
their… let’s call them blood donors. Usually
cows and horses, and almost never humans…
almost. They land on the ground near them,
gallop over in a not at all horrifying way,
and bite with their little sharp teeth. Incidentally
the common vampire bat is the only species
of bat in the world that can run. Then they
just kick back and lap up blood with their
tongues for the next half hour. The blood
doesn’t clot because the bat’s saliva
has an anticoagulant called desmoteplase (desmo-tea-plaze),
also known as draculin. Seriously. And yeah,
the bites may get infected but c’mon, it’s
not like vampire bats know about antiseptics.
Cut them some slack.
Alright I’m not doing a great job of defending
the bat’s honor but consider this: vampire
bats are actually really generous to each
other. You see, if a vampire bat goes two
days without feeding, it’ll starve. They’re
just tiny little mammals after all. They need
to be able to fly so they can’t have any
fat stores weighing them down. And if you
would just spare a little blood they’d be
fine, but no, you had to be selfish. Like
you need ALL your blood. But female vampire
bats are better people than you. If a friend
is going hungry, the bat will vomit blood
into its mouth. Isn’t that sweet?
It’s an example of a “you scratch my upside
down back, I scratch yours” philosophy,
or reciprocal altruism and was first reported
by University of Maryland biologist Gerald
Wilkinson in 1984. Female bats actually keep
track of who has helped them out in the past,
and when they’re asked to donate food to
their friends, they’ll do it without any
fuss. If they’re also on an empty stomach
that night, they’ll make up for it later
by being extra giving. And if they’ve damaged
a relationship in the past with selfishness,
they’ll work to repair it.
Vampire bats embody the spirit of the holidays.
They’re giving. They’re warm to each other,
in a literal sense when they huddle together
in groups. And bats love dark places and are
known to get into chimneys that aren’t sealed
up, so with a little nudging of the mythology
vampire bats can be a holiday symbol from
halloween through Christmas!
You wouldn’t even have to put cookies out
on the fireplace, the bats could just snack
on you!
And they usually number about a hundred but
can have groups as big as a thousand. Imagine
a thousand tiny flying Santas coming down
your chimney Christmas morning and sucking
your blood!
Alright I’m going to come clean, I know
this wasn’t a very convincing argument to
make vampire bats the embodiment of the season,
but my halloween decorations are still up
and at this point I’m just too embarrassed
to take them down, so just go with it?
Please?
For me?
If it makes you feel any better you’ll probably
never even see a vampire bat. Unless you live
in Central and South America. In which case
have you ever encountered vampire bats?
You should send me a pic on twitter, @JHug00,
that’s be really cool!
If I’ve freaked you out about bats a little
bit let me make it up to you. Check out this
video of how luna moths make bats look like
chumps!
Ok so who’s on board the vampire bat train?
Anyone?
Do you have a better idea for a holiday symbol?
Let us know in the comments, subscribe for
more, and I’ll see you next time on DNews.